what do you think so speaking of the
masculinity what do you think is hurting
young men the most these days that's
limiting their uh masculinity
oh man there's a lot
um you know I did a podcast the other
day with um Dr Anthony J he wrote this
interesting book called extra generation
it kind of goes down all of these
sources of environmental estrogens that
are lowering men's testosterone levels
and increasing estrogen levels and the
subtitle of his book is why you're fat
sicken and fertile today sort of thing
so that's so that's one of the most
interesting components like we were kind
of getting in the weeds and we were
talking about water and you know it got
to the point that a lot of source of
source of environmental ostriches comes
from uh City water lines because women
are mostly on birth control they pee
that into the sewage system sewage
systems can clean out large particles
but it can't clear out hormones so
there's estrogens in the water and if
you're drinking tap water you're now
drinking estrogens so I said to my go do
they know that this is in the water and
he said yeah they know I've I've visited
these places you know we've talked about
it they know there's estrogens in the
water so the government knows that
there's estrogenics in the water and
that it is softening Society is it
intentional I don't know you know let's
put on a tin foil hat we can go down for
a road trip on that one but there's lots
of things that are softening men I think
guys aren't guys aren't taking ownership
for their lives they've been told you
know to just
basically comply you know do what
everybody's told you to do just be a
nice guy go to school get a job you know
do the right thing
by the way they tell men and women
different things they tell guys you know
do the right thing they tell women you
do what's right for you girl right so
guys get this narrative that's been
beaten into them pretty much their
entire lives where they've been soffit
and it's no wonder why you see so many
guys right now walking around in their
20s with female breast tissue like they
they are just soft round versions of of
men that you know their grandfathers
would be rolling in their grave if they
knew about it right
what's your experience with one of these
soft men that
I mean I'll be honest like as a woman
when you meet that like it is I could
see why women find that comforting
because sometimes those manly men can be
a little bit aggressive to women so
that's why that type of soft men is
almost embraced by women yeah but those
soft men end up in the friend zone right
exactly right right those soft men
well I don't do that okay um but yes you
would I wouldn't look at them in a way
of marriage control too though right say
that again because when women are in
hormonal birth control they like softer
guys
uh right so one of the problems that
women end up with when they get married
is okay maybe they're on hormonal birth
control dating the guy leading up to the
marriage they like him you know Tim's a
nice soft guy he buys her flowers texts
her in the morning hey babe how you
doing sort of thing and then she comes
off hormonal birth control when they get
married maybe she gets knocked up maybe
she doesn't but a lot of women after
they get married and they come off birth
control they realize huh I don't really
like this guy so much I kind of like the
alpha guy over there oh look there's
Kevin in sales let's go talk to him
shout out to Kevin tapping everyone's
girlfriend I stay away from those things
because I know those things are it's
like manually moving your hormones and
like I even have issues taking like
Advil just because you don't really know
necessarily like what's going on inside
of those pills so I guess the next
question is Richard how can you balance
being a traditional man and but dealing
with modern women today because it's not
like we can go back in time and and and
and and
reinvent women and be like all right I
want you to be more feminine and more
friendly and fit and all the good stuff
that we're used to how we want women to
be we're dealing with with modern women
today and whether that's a good thing or
a bad thing we can address but we are
dealing with women of today how can a
traditional Alpha Man or even just a
normal man balance living their life and
dealing with modern women
oh man that's that's a long conversation
too I wish we had more time are you
talking about a traditional man in the
sense of like like the like the transcon
Avatar kind of like a Matt Walsh sort of
guy no like uh just a guy like you and
me we're out there you know we we we're
making money guys like you and me
understand the way things work my friend
right like we've unplugged from The
Matrix sort of thing so you know for
guys like you and me it's okay well
let's not invite chaos into our life
stay away from women with loads of red
flags with daddy issues has been run
through by a bunch of guys covered in
tattoos like you know these are things
that we are smart enough to look for so
we don't complicate our lives
unnecessarily but I mean a lot of the
times like I'll give a guy my book or
I'll just say hey you know often my
email list and get the 20 red flag
chapter and they get mad it's like well
there's no women if we just you know
like if I have to vet them all with
these 20 here then I'm never going to
get a girl rich
okay well that's that's the reality of
society today the reason why I give you
these tools is so that you can see them
for what they are understand them and
then you know adapt accordingly but what
they don't seem to understand is well if
that's all that you see then that's all
that you are worth do more work on
yourself become more competent you know
learn more about gain learn more about
you know whatever is it you got to sort
of fix your mouth maybe you're boring as
[__] I don't know but if all you see is
is 20 red flags and every single woman
that you talk to there's something wrong
with you I'm in an LTR my gal is great
there's lots of women out there that
don't have red flags do the work on
yourself and they will become available
to you yeah speaking of being a boring
of [__] what's the the famous phrase or
quote I've heard you say this before
about being boring and how women
perceive boring men
you can do anything to women except for
them right like you have to be
captivating as a man right like when
when you've got money then I would
assume that you're doing cool [__] I
mean there's a absurd number of guys
that have like that are weapons in
business they've built incredible
businesses that make lots of money but
it's like you know what do you do for
fun
um I like watching Netflix series really
like that's what you do for fun like you
don't you don't travel you don't have a
boat you don't like planes you don't
like fast cars like you don't do
anything interesting that you can say
hey babe you know we're going on a
Supercar rally for the afternoon down to
the winery you want to come in my
McLaren oh yeah like women like that
kind of stuff be interesting it's not
that difficult yeah and if she asks well
Richard I would go but what color is
your McLaren before I go that's a red
flag right there it's like just getting
a [__] McLaren shut your mouth
um so maybe a better question is
how can men vet women better because
listen
full disclosure
I'm not a car guy I'm not I don't have
hobbies I'm not doing rock climbing I'm
not going mountain climbing I live in
South Beach I don't go surfing I don't
collect baseball cards I like to do
three things I like to hang out with my
homies I like to make money and do [__]
I like to hang out with hot chicks
period end of story you now know saws so
we men have a weakness for pretty women
no doubt whether they're you know right
for you or wrong for you men have this
weakness this is how civilization
continues to Prevail is because men have
babies and children so I guess my
question when it comes to vetting women
what women should men steer clear of no
matter what especially in a long-term
relationship and if you do want a
long-term relationship what type of
women should you pursue or run towards
in your life so who should you avoid and
who should you go towards as a man
I would recommend avoiding any of the
women that have a load of red flags that
aren't being worked on so if you don't
know what the red flags are it's in my
book you don't have to get the book you
can opt in my email list and get it for
free just go to my channel and it's it's
there or maybe the um admin team can put
it below in the video
um so that's really what you should be
voting for but let's say you know for
example she's the kind of gal that has
um like an addictive personality to
shopping and she realizes that she has a
shopping addiction she likes going and
buying three lamps she brings them home
tries them up beside the bed it's a
table they don't work out so she has to
return them and this is what she does
with her weekends well if she recognizes
that that's a problem and that she has
an addictive personality and it and it
takes care of her free time and she's
doing something about it that's good
okay it's a red flag that she's
identified but now she's taking
ownership for it and she's doing
something for it okay so just having the
red flag may not be a complete deal
breaker I mean a deal breaker would be
she's covered from head to toe and
Tattoos okay there's not much you can do
about that for example but some of the
red flags are fixable if they take
ownership for it the second part to that
was you're saying what kind of women
like any girls with tattoos high body
counts addictive personalities
shopaholics materialistic my favorite is
uh high maintenance women stay the [__]
away from those men uh women gentlemen
what's that
you can't handle me gals right now maybe
you're not doing enough for me Richard
that whole deal
um so we know who to avoid who what type
of women should a man gravitate towards
or at least pull into their
gravitational gravitational world
well I think if you vote for the red
flags you're going to be left with a far
better pool of women to choose from
right and you know then you want to look
for women that are more agreeable
they're going to be a compliment to your
life like if you're a man on a purpose
you're on a mission you're doing
something you're putting a dent in the
universe and if I text my girl and she's
heading over and I say hey you know can
you grab a bottle of wine you know
dinner will be ready or you know I got
dinner ordered it's going to be here at
a certain time and she picks up a bottle
of wine or she asks you know which one
do I want sort of thing or like you know
she's compliant like she's helpful yeah
right
um you know she sees it you know laundry
needs to be done and she's oh okay you
know let me take care of that I'll throw
the load of the machine and give you a
hand sort of thing like women that are
useful in your life are a far better
choice than women that are like well I'm
not going to do anything I don't cook
okay
um you know to me that would be a red
flag you know woman that's not owning
her feminine frame there's a buddy of
mine that I've known for a long time and
he calls these Blue Jobs and pink jobs
and he says one of the reasons why his
marriage is so successful as his wife
does the pink jobs and he does the blue
jobs she's not out cutting the grass
she's in the kitchen preparing dinner
for the family while he cuts the grass
sort of thing right so you know if you
identify these you know more traditional
roles that sort of served with what
we're interested in what we're good at
then that's then that's a woman that you
might want to consider saying oh she
looks like she might be good mother
stock yeah I think you know we're
identifying you know vetting women and
identifying the type of women that you
should steer clear of and the women that
you should avoid versus the women that
you should have in your life the more
and more I think about this kind of
stuff you know this is a financial
podcast that really highlights how money
affects dating relationships who you
marry all that fun stuff the more and
more I have these conversations with
bright you know philosophers like like
yourself the more I realize that like
the same terminology and money also
applies to dating as an example you want
a woman in your life who is an asset not
a liability ability right and and that's
a lot of times what these red flags in
women is they create chaos in your life
they become a liability versus someone
who's useful willing to do the pink jobs
so to speak while you can do the Blue
Jobs and she's an asset in your life and
that's how you can grow your kingdom I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out